one one thing i do do in the morning to
like get me into like the work mode if
i'm at home all day is that i don't wear
like my pajama shirt i like change to a
different shirt pajama shirt you have a
pajama shirt yeah just like old shirts
that i don't wear shirts to bed why do
you do that
i wear shoes to bed because i don't want
to people do this because i don't want
to be naked because i just it just feels
like i don't like this it's just boxes i
don't know it just doesn't feel
comfortable yeah if it feels like a it
feels like unless i'm in a sleeping bag
i don't have enough cover over me yeah i
feel really bare yeah yeah and
unprotected like like boxes
i love using the body parts as
temperature control so i put some out
puts them in you know depending on how
much how cold the heart needs to be
okay but do you okay do you wear boxes
to bed yeah sometimes naked sometimes
boxers
see are like i need to wear boxes to bed
sleeping like completely naked just
feels weird yeah i'm used to thing you
know because the nut sack is a very
delicate thing to kind of like
you laugh but nothing
your nuts go everywhere and sometimes
they're more elastic than other times so
it's uh
sometimes you just don't want your nut
sack rubbing against your leg you know
like i don't know like for me
you're not so huge that they're like a
[ __ ] sack of potatoes like oh [ __ ]
them out of the way when when when i'm
not wearing a shirt to sleep it just
feels weird to feel my own skin on my
skin no i get that like like you know
yeah it's it's exactly the same like the
only time i will you've been like
brainwashed the other time the only time
where i will go to bed without a shirt
on is if it's like excruciatingly hot to
the point where like even the ac on
blast isn't going to do it for me yeah
like i mean i like but i mean like i
need some fabric on me too yeah
uh that sounded really like epidermis
2.0
it's comfortable end of story i just i
don't understand why you would feel
uncomfortable with the other shirt okay
and another thing sometimes sometimes if
i'm not wearing a shirt my body gets
even hotter right because you have like
a natural body temperature and if it's
like skin on skin sometimes it like it's
like a it's like a loop system where
like warms itself up a bit more i don't
know if that's just me i think that's
[ __ ] i think you've got insulation
the heat more no no i mean like
insulation works both ways right like if
you put if you put a if you put a jacket
on a snowman right it's it's it
insulates the heat in it it's nice like
they actually they actually say to
preserve body heat like in like super
cold temperatures when you sleep it's
actually better to sleep naked than to
wear something
i just i just watched like worse i just
think that you know it's you meant to
sleep naked i just thought that was what
you're supposed to do where'd you get
this idea from [ __ ]
how god intended
like
oh god sleeps naked why why why wear
clothing which seems like a lot more
effort to be wearing clothes to bed like
why are you complicating it effort yeah
just go naked it's how hard is it to put
a shirt on for you i just think why are
you adding shirts into an equation that
doesn't need it you know
why why why do you like so then okay
question then yeah why need blankets
it's a question then right why not just
sleep on a slab serious question okay so
then when you start you know you start
doing the business you know you just
throw the [ __ ] off yeah yeah oh that
just seems like a lot of work i'm always
i'm always ready it's two seconds
when you when you jack off do you wear a
shirt depends where i am
it's never really an part of the
equation of jacking off i'm just like do
i have my shirt on i feel like i'm like
the michelin man when i'm jacking off
wearing a shirt i feel like i'm like
constricted i'm like [ __ ] hell like
get the [ __ ] off of me what are you
[ __ ] you it's like it's like do you
[ __ ] bulk up when you've been have
you never done the business with a shirt
on i have i don't like it it feels like
i'm i'm like i'm in some kind of like
constriction
i don't like it at all don't like it no
it feels strange i don't mind it no
sometimes you need to like you know
sometimes it's not the reason why you
know in porn they don't take they take
the [ __ ] off you know it's because you
want to get like well that's because
they're on [ __ ] camera mate yeah but
are you on camera it might be
but also it's like you know when you're
pooping sometimes you have to take your
shirt off yeah yeah yeah but that's more
of just like the same kind of energy
well that's the thing it's like because
it's intense i'll take it no no not
every poop needs to say you need to take
a shower i don't prefer if you speak for
yourself you know when you wake up i you
know when you wake up right and you've
the first poop do you take the shirt off
when you do it you just right no i keep
it on the poop like the shirt taking off
poops are for the poops that like fight
back yeah
it's it's when like you need to like
like you you need that extra push
those are the poops that are like no i'm
staying here
the ones in the morning are kind of just
like all right good night generally
prefer to just take it off when i prove
anyway why not not like during the day
if i'm like out in like it like a public
restroom
it goes for a proof and just like he
likes takes off like the jojo's suit and
i took it over and takes off the tie
takes off the shirt
and i'd still poop faster than gone
i don't know it's just like a placebo
right it's like i just feel more
comfortable wearing a shirt to bed i
don't know what it is i think you've
you've nerfed yourself
in what way have we nerfed ourselves how
i feel like you've nerfed yourself no
because i can i can poop without any
requirements you know what it also is it
doesn't sound like that because it
sounds like your requirement is that you
need to take a shirt off that you need
you need to have nothing
that's that's literally a requirement we
don't i can sleep naked i just prefer to
have a shower you're stranded without a
shirt then i'll sleep with my show he's
he's a wrestler he'll be complaining the
whole time he's a reason he's a reason
as well though because like i've
actually experienced this where like i
in the middle of the night we're in
japan right earthquakes right that
happen all the [ __ ] time right if
there's a massive earthquake in the
middle of the night i don't want to be
that weirdo running out of my house but
[ __ ] naked
are you okay
you have time to grab your clothes well
then why don't you just wear the shirt
at that point then i'm not if you have
the time
to wear a shirt
ready for combat situations every
[ __ ] night i haven't got a draw full
of passports ready to go because i need
to be deported you know i this t-shirt
is on the floor this one extra second to
putting on the t-shirt which i can do on
the way to the elevator or some [ __ ] you
know i don't need to wait an element
is i'm not walking downstairs i just
have this like mental image of just like
if if an earthquake happens when conor
is either sleeping or on the toilet it's
just going to be that scene from borat
all over again
kind of just like emerges
if i'm [ __ ] in the middle of an
earthquake i'm taking my chances i'm
going to carry on doing what i'm doing
i'm not
why would i run out i'm i feel like
running out is just a stupid idea just
stay in your house maybe yeah if you die
[Music]
no it is it is a very specific situation
of course like uh
evacuated in uh l.a i felt like we did
not need to evacuate i felt like we
should have just stayed in our room i
don't know what the recommended
guideline is but i'm pretty sure running
down to the bottom floor is not the
right idea
i would say not using the elevator
during an earthquake is probably like at
the top of like yeah i just had [ __ ] to
do after it so i really wanted to get
down fast so i was
it's chick-fil-a nuggets weren't going
to eat themselves as well and also i the
moment that i was immediately put off
going down the stairs was when we ran
past the american family and that guy
was acting like we were in like a
hollywood movie and we had like he had
like three kids and he was like
kids stay with me stay with your daddy
we got to go down together as a team
hold hands and i was like i'm like i'm
not i'm not being in this guy's movie
i'm gonna do my own thing i don't want
to be part of this that's that's when i
decided that i did like it was a pretty
tense situation but the moment i heard
that
i was just like the earthquake had ended
you know it was like whatever i was not
really scared anymore the building was
still shaking but i was like whatever
it's not a big deal the building's built
for it yeah the building's built
different yeah to understand this with
standards so i was pretty confident that
we were going to be fine yeah so i was
like whatever i think i i'll take the
elevator
i didn't i realized that don't take
emergency advice from no no i'm not
he just does it anyway i was just you
know i was i felt confident enough that
i was going to be fine
and if i died you know sure i can have
my darwin award in peace uh because i'm
dead so
a tangential sense where you just like
willingly put your life in danger just
for a bit of confidence i don't feel
like it was in danger because i didn't
feel that way because like living living
in thailand this is going a complete
tangent every time you get in the car no
no no no no
no no no that's that's not a risk that's
not risking your life okay bangkok is
the only place i've lived in where
people
willingly lift uh risk their lives in
the daily by taking a motorcycle type a
motor motorcycle taxi like daily in like
some of the most dangerous roads in the
world just to save yourself 30 minutes
of traffic right right and we do that on
the daily and i do that on a daily i'm
just like that's weird when you think
about it i i can't really describe why i
just wanted to take the elevator but i
think i just realized i was like i could
either walk down 70 floors of stairs or
i could just risk it and take the
elevator and i think at that point in
time to me taking 70 flight of stairs
was not worth my life
well i mean i can't i can't argue
against that because i also went in the
elevator
i think it was one of those things i was
like connor it was like connor's going
in the elevator or if he's stupid enough
to risk his life i guess i feel
confident enough where yeah oh i'll go
in with it i can blame the connor if i
die yeah exactly i don't know i know
that i shouldn't do it but i did so i
mean we ended up not going down anyway
yes what ended up happening was cosmic
justice is that the elevator to get down
you had to go up to the 70th floor yeah
the lobby to then get down and when we
got to the 70th floor uh they stopped
all the elevators yeah so basically we
went down about 35 stairs for nothing
yeah basically just instant karma yeah
and then we waited 10 minutes and the
elevator started working and then it was
no problem and i was very glad that i
did yeah i literally looked back at like
what the [ __ ] i mean
was like went down 70 flights of stairs
turned around was like but you know i
you know when when stuff like that
happens i feel like i don't want to be
that guy who's panicking and running
around like all these people you know
that's the last thing to do i just feel
like this is happy sheep
wake up sheeple this is how you're
inviting a shitty situation to happen
you know um
you know and i also don't want to try my
chances on on the road uh because you
know because when you leave the hotel
you're just facing the road yeah i don't
want to try my chances with stuff
falling or people driving off yeah
earthquake
i was pretty content that my room was
fine yeah i was like well that's the
thing is like in some situations it's
actually more dangerous to go on the
road because in the case of japan we
have so much like electrical wiring on
the roads that if those fall and snap
they can easily electrocute you [ __ ]
you know uh traffic signs can come down
hurt you yeah well i feel like the
safest place is just to probably be on
the ground floor yeah the building i
don't know but you get way more uh like
earthquake vibrations on the first floor
yeah yeah the best thing the higher up
the building the less you get like you
just get swaying if you're up top yeah
and when you're down below you get the
[ __ ] violent shaking yeah the best
thing to do is to just go out into like
a really really good market
i feel like this is a point in my life
where i'm just like i don't know if i
should uh listen to this
buildings are built on like rolling
mechanics yeah uh so when the building
you you [ __ ] experienced it what do
you mean the hotel we've stayed in yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's built on rollers so
that when the earthquake happens it
starts rolling yeah but on like the
ground floor
sometimes you literally don't even feel
the earthquake no because there's no
there's no swaying or anything like that
no because you're you're getting like
the actual [ __ ] earth shaking that's
that's that's not what it feels like on
the ground floor yeah it does
there's an earthquake on the ground
floor right yeah it feels very violently
shaking yeah but it's kind of the same
as being on the building i i when i
experienced both in japan i definitely
preferred in la when the building was
just swaying i like i i was literally on
the street and sometimes i didn't even
notice that there was an earthquake when
people were yeah yeah yeah
because like i there was there's no
there's nothing to like how can i put
this there's nothing to put your
perspective in that you're in an
earthquake you just feel like the floor
is a bit wobbly the thought doesn't the
floor doesn't move it shakes it does
[ __ ] it shakes it shakes but a lot of
the times you can't actually see it
moving until you look at something yeah
there's
there's nothing to like ground your
perspective whereas if you're in a
building you can see other buildings
doing this yeah yeah exactly like i
don't really most of the times i don't
even realize i'm in an earthquake until
i have something to like ground that
perspective right sometimes i'm just
sometimes
like living in japan sometimes i just
get up get a head rush i'm like oh was
that enough
like like you ever forget
there's so many like earthquakes but
like you know when you're getting an
earthquake because you should be like
just [ __ ]
i'm like my mom has the story of when
she was in school she was like running
along the tracks at school and like you
know when you're running like your
entire world is doing this yeah so she
was running and she was looking at the
school building and then she stopped and
the building just kept doing this and
she realized she was in an earthquake
and she didn't realize until she stopped
because to her perspective it's already
going up and down right yeah but then
it's it's i think it again it's that
like perspective of being like that's
not
moving the way it's intended to but also
i i don't you know the shake the swaying
and all that stuff i don't really give a
[ __ ] as long as like you know the
building isn't falling down
yeah and i just don't want my stuff to
break well yeah that's that's that's the
biggest thing it's just like [ __ ]
falling down isn't it yeah that's why
whenever there was an earthquake i would
just rush to my like camera gear i'm
like
hold my shoulders sick
[Music]
those are the real casualties and
earthquakes i had those like 400 500
jojo figures that were like very finely
balanced yeah that were like balanced
the weight was like like this so the
center of gravity was very worrying yeah
and during earthquakes i immediately had
to just like go to them if i was there
and during that we had we had one pretty
big earthquake and i was surprised
because my figures just stayed well i
mean same with the studio as well yours
didn't yeah it's weird because the
figures the figures that we they had
fallen looked like pretty normal figures
but the one that i really expected to
break didn't move at all well i mean
it's the same here as well like when at
the old trafford i expected like rohan
to just be over all of these like
knocked over but the only casualty we
had was [ __ ] mike [ __ ] mike
every time i'm not at my house and
there's an earthquake in japan i just
assume my house is going to be
demolished when i'm back i'm like
everything's [ __ ] i have to rebuild my
whole life it's all ruined